we start in Mozambique which has been
reeling from five years of conflict and
a violent Insurgency in the northern
Cabo Delgado Province more than 4 000
people have been killed and nearly 1
million were forced to flee their homes
while attacks on civilians continue some
areas are now under government control
after troops from Southern Africa and
Rwanda were deployed to help fight the
Insurgency DW was given rare access to
join Rwandan soldiers on patrol in
mosimbua De praia where the situation is
slowly returning to normal
a year ago this town was run by islamist
insurgents their main base was at the
airport but these troops chased them
away Rwandan forces supporting
Mozambique
today life is slowly getting back to
normal those who fled are returning
people were killed here they were
murdered they were slaughtered cut into
pieces so we ran away but now that
there's peace we've decided to come back
at the beach the people resumed their
livelihoods and go out fishing again
mom has also returned to the Village of
Kinga displaced residents like Abdullah
pinti back home after a whole year away
seeking Refuge
there were gunshots so we ran out of the
house
and then my father
we look back and then my mother said
Abdallah your father has been shot look
he's not getting up
his body was left there for three days
when Abdallah pinti came back he found
his home had been looted but at least
not burned down like many others now
he's trying to farm again
lots of the young people have no work
they sit there doing nothing but since
the Rwandan Army arrived we've had peace
my mother and I can go to work in the
fields again
while the residents are relieved to be
back they're not happy with their
government which fail to protect them
from the brutal insurgents
they also accuse government troops of
heavy-handedness when they eventually
arrived
we expected better from our countrymen
when they meet us on the streets they
stop us and they mistreat us instead of
going after the enemy
at one of their checkpoints a young man
on a motorcycle fell the soldiers all
started beating him until he died
they've killed a lot of people it's not
good
soldiers deny the accusations and
mozambique's defense Ministry has not
responded to our questions on the claims
what's certain though is the conflict is
far from over
in fact it's moving further south where
attacks on Villages are reported almost
daily now even in neighboring provinces
like nampula farther away from where the
troops from Rwanda and the regional
block sadec are based
and keep moving southwards so that is
expected so you just not need to
maintain vigilance
the forces the Sadiq as well as our own
forces will maintain vigilance in the
areas that we occupy and for the areas
that are Beyond carbon Delgado like
napula uh the mozambican process will
need to also up their game
that increased vigilance will be vital
here because the residents worry the
threat could still return
I spoke to Fernando Lima he's a
journalist and political commentator
based in maputo and I began by asking
him what impact the Rwandan troops and
the southern African troops have had in
this fight against the Insurgency
everyone and troops are the backbone of
the government's fight against
Insurgency Capital God they are the most
effective Force there as you know they
are also sadak troops which is the
original
Coalition that have about more than 2
000 troops in Camden but the real
effective force uh in kab Delgado is the
Rwandan Army and the Rwandan police and
they have been stretched uh in my point
of view too much in the last few months
in order to address other military
situations in or other parts of kab
Delgado but their job in districts like
musibo de prai and Palma have been uh uh
very very good and all military analysts
are convinced that their job and their
presence there have been crucial in
order to stop violence in those two
districts which are the Strategic
districts for the oil and gas projects
there now at the same time there are
also strong accusations against the
Mozambique soldiers for using excessive
violence against civilians and even
authorities are accused of corruption
what more do you know about those human
rights violations committed by
Mozambique and troops
the mozambican Army does not have proper
training and so lack of discipline is
part of that training that they should
have but they they do not have and so
this means that
disgruntled units instead of portray
their mission they uh go to the
population abuse women and arrests
families in looking for food for example
and why are they looking for food
because they do not have enough food in
their military units so they then arrest
the population trying to feed themselves
with with the population they are
supposed to protect
and given all that how confident are you
that the mozin beacon authorities would
be able to reinstate peace
well
[Music]
uh military Specialists believed that it
will take at least three years in order
to have a proper uh Army handling uh the
situation in Delgado and now more
broadly looking at what's behind this
conflict is there a connection between
the armed group and the fight for
mozambique's natural resources what I
think it's Unique in cup Delgado is a
combination of factors in which you
unite poverty you unite frustration but
you also have this kind of cement that
unite unite people for a cause which is
uh religion and
Islamic
Islamic clerics business themselves from
these Insurgency but you can and find
some kind of uh
arguments about a certain Islam which is
disclaimed by mainstream Islam which
unite these people and then you have the
connection lose or not you have the
connection with the Islamic Islamic
State in which now Mozambique is is
considered a prophet so this is the the
Melting Pot that probably have put all
these people uh United and fighting
together so yes there are lots of
factors that explain what's going on in
capital God but no I don't think that
that the
the the the natural resources and
exploration of natural resources are the
main causes because you we have natural
resources in other parts of Mozambique
and we do not have any armored conflicts
in other parts of the country
that is Fernando Lima speaking to us
from maputo thank you very much indeed
for your time
now we briefly touched on how much of
Mozambique is rich in natural resources
Cabo Delgado has huge gas and gold
reserves and also the biggest Ruby mine
in the world DW's Adrian Creech visited
the mine in the northern town of Monte
puej to see if the country's wealth and
revenue is reaching the people who need
it
the Ruby minus unhightened alert the
attacks by insurgents are getting closer
and the violence is only one of the
problems facing the security team
and they start blocking the roots again
because these kids are just coming to
make trouble
every day up to 200 people illegally
enter the open cast mine hoping to share
in the Region's mineral wealth using
simple tools they dig tunnels up to 15
meters deep the mine uses drone Pilots
to track the illegal mining coordinating
with the security team
keep going okay here stop
this time only one of the men is caught
he'll go straight to jail and could face
a sentence of up to five years
please I have a four-year-old daughter
and a wife
you feel sorry for these guys because if
you look at the if you look at the area
they're moving I mean yes there is a
mine here yes we we can only accommodate
so many people in terms of employment
you can't give employment to everyone
just in this facilities of our mind
we're looking at about 80 000 displaced
people from Monte Pierce up to nanjua
what do what do that people do for an
income
they they get involved in this
in a village in the middle of the mine
concession we meet a group of young men
artisanal miners they say they have no
other options none of them got a job at
the mine
we're suffering here
there's no work I have no choice but to
search for rubies
and it's not lucrative either I just
came back from digging 10 shafts and I
found nothing but still they hunt us
down and arrest us even if we don't have
anything
foreign
the company shows off its social
projects Farms mobile health clinics and
schools but above all it pays plenty of
taxes says mine manager Claudius
nongonima
upwards of 25 percent of our gross
revenues have been to the compared to
the government in terms of production
taxes and royalties and that's a
significant amount of money but how much
of that reaches the people here a
government representative in the region
shows us a list of projects and asks for
patience
in the past this District wasn't like it
is today we didn't have the health
facilities that we have now in The
Villages around the mine there are
classrooms for the school children there
is growth happening but I don't believe
anyone expects us to become rich
overnight with all these resources
but there isn't much time left for the
Region's poorest to get some benefit
from the gemstone wealth in as little as
10 years the Ruby reserves here could be
exhausted
poverty and the lack of prospects are
plain to see some who don't try to get
their hands on rubies rely on catching
rodents to feed their families